et on termine par ce reportage tourné
par nos équipes à madagascar 45000
tonnes c'est la quantité de miel
consommée en france chaque année avec
une production intérieure en baisse et
une demande en hausse est la part de
miel importé ne cesse de croître
problème ils sont souvent chargés en
pesticides ou métaux lourds
face à ce constat un entrepreneur belge
installé à madagascar a décidé de
relancer la filière du miel tout en
préservant l'environnement
un sujet signé sa raté tous et à la bi
licence sur la côte est de madagascar
la récolte du miel de niaouli s'étend
sur un mois
cette végétation luxuriante
approvisionne généreusement les abeilles
des 75 ruche d'andry en hectares et avec
ses social 15e lui serait faite tous les
miels des nerfs ou les mais elle
de quoi douter après ça mlt nichi mail
de mokrane 1
ce ne sont pas les espèces mellifères
qui manque dans la région de man a car
comme le niaouli l'eucalyptus est
recherché pour ses vertus anti viral
pour relancer la filière apicole à
l'export
il n'a fallu qu'un déclic à cet
entrepreneur belge la levée en 2011 de
l'embargo de l'union européenne sur les
exportations des produits malgaches
d'origine animale ses bons côtés par
nord pour parade main un million et demi
d'euros investis pour des installations
à la pointe dans une miellerie flambant
neuf
comme cette salle de déshumidification
une exigence de l'union européenne
les milieux tropicaux un taux d'humidité
supérieur à 20% qui va jusqu'en 1 24%
mais tolérance européenne bloc à
l'importation en europe maximum 20 pour
faire diminuer pour faciliter la récolte
d'une centaine de tonnes de miel à
l'année l'entreprise a également investi
dans ses camions extracteur de
véritables miellerie mobile capable de
rejoindre 1500 apiculteurs en brousse
jusque dans les ruchers les plus
reculées la demande française par
exemple de créances 45000 tonnes par an
et en france on produit à peu près entre
sept et dix mille tonnes annuelles donc
il ya un manque de miel dont il ya un
besoin d'importations miel est
actuellement le premier vendeur de miel
en france est un fournisseur chinois
à l'heure où de plus en plus d'études
révèle la présence de traces de
pesticides et de métaux lourds dans les
milieux européens et asiatiques
le miel malgache récoltés dans ces
régions vierge de toute pollution
conquièrent de nouveaux marchés dans le
nord-ouest de madagascar à quelques
kilomètres de la ville dans band la
présence des ruches a déjà montré ses
effets bénéfiques dans les vergers est
alloué
gymnase avant on récoltait deux ou trois
charrette d'orange par exemple depuis
qu'on a installé ses ruches en 2015 ces
8 à 10 l'apiculture va apporter un
revenu complémentaire pour les
apiculteurs mais nous on espère dans les
années à venir que ce soit la source de
revenus primaires elle les rouches et se
situe à proximité des mangroves sur la
zone d'abandon nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires qui sont blue ventures et ld
tu as deux ong pour combiner pratiques
apicoles et conservation de ce milieu
tout aussi précieux qu en danger ces
espèces de palétuviers son butinée par
les abeilles
mais elles sont aussi la cible des
braconniers qui coupent le bois pour le
revendre sous forme de charbon donc on
perd presque 5% en fait tous les ans de
la forêt de mangrove et sinon le
district d'amande
c'est en 2016 qu'on a identifié
l'apiculture comme une activité
complémentaire de revenus et on a
vraiment ciblé des personnes qui étaient
impliqués dans le secteur de la
production de charbon de mangrove c'est
le cas d'ahmed ali formé en 2016
l'ex braconniers enseigne aujourd'hui
les techniques apicoles dans les
villages alentour comme
le la times avant nous coupions le bois
de mangrove pour le vendre à nos cibles
mais la mangrove est une source de
nourriture pour les abeilles comme les
villageois commencent à réparer ce qui
est détruit l'un des sabots voise un peu
plus de 3 euros par litre de miel les
revenus de l'apiculture pour ce marché à
l'export peuvent largement rivaliser
avec ceux du charbonnage et convaincre à
la reconversion dans les zones rurales
de la grande île